well we're pleased to have Jim gortney
here with us this morning Jim gortney is
professor of economics and also director
of the Stavros center for economic
education at florida state university
Jim is perhaps best known is the
co-author of economics private and
public choice a great economics textbook
that is now in its 13th 15th I'm two
editions behind 15th edition how many
have read Jim's textbook a lot Jim
including Jim how many have your
students read it okay good quite a few
there too excellent he is also co-author
of economic freedom of the world an
annual report that provides data on the
institutions and policies of 141
countries Jim is past president of the
Southern Economic Association and the
association for free enterprise
education a member of the mont pelerin
society Courtney was invited by the
Putin administration in march of 2000 to
make presentations and have discussions
with leading russian economists about
the future of the russian economy they
didn't listen in 2004 Jim received the
Adam Smith award of the Association of
private enterprise education Jim's topic
today is common sense economics / life
please welcome Jim Courtney
could I have you with us today okay
thanks bird bird mentioned that part
about Vladimir Putin didn't listen
actually he did listen but not for very
long the major focus of what the
meetings that we had had to do with
their tax policy and essentially they
had a marginal tax rates counting both
payroll and income what ran to something
like seventy percent and we were able to
convince him he that wasn't a very good
idea in any case you have seventy-five
percent of your income that's going to
unreported so you might do better to
charge lower rates which if you'll
recall russia did institute a flat rate
tax at thirteen percent but that was
long ago in terms of the reason why i
was invited is because of andre laranov
was who was involved with us from the
economic freedom of the world project
from very early on was putin's chief
economist and a lot of people don't
really realize that when putin first ran
the first time they was elected after
being a poder he ran as a sort of reform
type of candidate and he was open to
these kinds of ideas but as in a case of
so many of our own political leaders
that once they get there with the ring
of power on their hand that it becomes
difficult for them to stand up to it
well in any case i want to think with
you a little bit about economics and
delivery of economics and i must say
that the i found it to be a very
fascinating morning and in many ways
it's kind of an introduction to what
John and I want to share with you in the
sense that we think that education the
delivery of education is in a transition
and obviously there's been a lot of
changes in the last few years but I
expected it's going to continue and
maybe even as recently as five years
from now we'll sort of look back and
sort of say man I can't believe we did
it that way way back there in 2014 one
of the things that sort of comes out of
our morning discussion as online
education means a lot of different
kinds of things and it involves
different types of delivery systems and
we developed a package called common
sense economics for life which is built
around the little book coming since
economics which I'm going to get to and
share a little bit with you but
essentially what we are trying to do is
it's Gary mentioning to hillsdale reach
as many people as possible with the
sound economics and we were a little bit
set back when we kind of in looked at
what the statistics are in terms of
economics you know sixty percent of
students in the United States graduate
from college without ever taking a
course in economics now a lot of us are
involved in principles of economics and
the book that Burt mentioned economics
private-public choice is designed for a
micro and macro principles class which
is predominantly those classes are taken
by his economics majors and business
majors but there's a whole other
universe of students out there who don't
take any economics and if they do take
economics they take micro and macro
principles which to a large degree we
either really turn them off about they
say you know I can't believe anybody is
interested in this tough or that we're
not really giving them what they need to
know so what we set out to do with
common sense economics was to develop a
course that really covered what if
students were going to take only one
course in economics this course we think
really hits on the things that are most
important for them to know we are doing
it with regard to communicating these
sort of broader set of concepts and
ideas which are practical and have
relevance to to people's lives in a
number of different ways first our
economics 2000 course now this is a
course that's taken by students who are
neat majoring in neither business nor
economics this course the economic
common sense economics for life the core
part of it is in fact that course we
teach it both online and we teach it in
a seated class
and we teach it in with a lot of video
clips a lot of in some cases some audio
type of readings but really focusing on
making it interesting and even fun and
we have various types of activities
built into it that that illustrate the
importance of the concepts so that's
kind of that's one of the things that we
do a second thing that we do is we want
to improve the quality of teaching of
economics at the high school level and I
must say I've been a little bit
surprised to find out that high school
teachers at least some of them are
really quite eager to learn more about
economics and learn more about how to
improve their teaching at the high
school class we now offer an online
course designed for high school teachers
involving a lot of the video clips and
everything that actually John is going
to take you through so i won't go into
too much about that but where you offer
it for it's a non-credit but it's the
very same courses are kind of actually
embellished version of our economics
2000 taken by in on economics
non-business majors at FSU and the
course is available for sixty dollars
anybody can sign up for it and that it's
a regular 15-week kind of course there's
online there's an instructor involved
with it and interaction with them and we
we really get to know these teachers and
then at the end of the course and we
make this available right up front at
the end of the course will make this
entire package available to them on
blackboard or Moodle or whatever kind of
course management system that they might
be interested in so a third thing that
we're now experimenting with that starts
actually November third the very first
one is on canvas we're offering and
abridged version of common sense
economics for life free of charge as a a
MOOC and we didn't know what kind of
results to get it opened up about a
month ago and we're not up into the kind
of number
that hillsdale was talking about what
we're expecting we already have close to
a thousand students that are signed up
for that MOOC there's information we
have a table in the back Fred France and
as will be back there at that table and
that the information is about the MOOC
and how you might want to sign up and if
you would like to know more about this
course that that's information will be
available at the booth back there well
let me turn a little bit to the sort of
outlining what common sense economics
for life is built around the book some
of you are probably familiar I guess I
should take a pull Bert but the blind
man can't tell how many people are
raising their hands so why do what I
want to take a poll the common-sense
economics what everyone should know
about wealth and prosperity is really a
book that the 20 ferry knee and Dwight
Lee and Rick's troop and i put together
designed to be cover the things that we
think that students really ought to know
that's kind of out of our larger
textbook but we general eliminate all
the graphs i think the book itself has
only one supply demand graphs a few
other graphs presenting some data now
the package has more graphics and
dynamic kinds of stuff but we don't want
to intimidate students it's organized to
be very user-friendly divided into four
parts the first part is twelve key
elements in the economic way of thinking
we make a simple statement like
incentives matter and that's where you
start it's a basic positive economics
that what gives economics the power is
the fact that people respond to
incentives in a predictable way and so
we give a brief explanation of what the
statement is then show a number of
applications to it so in as you might
anticipate in sort of 12 key elements we
cover things like the importance of
exchange gains from trade opportunity
costs of course supply demand role of
profits and losses of invisible hand and
remembering the secondary effects and
highlighting that it's important to
integrate into your economic way of
thinking that in addition to the direct
elements that a lot of changes also have
indirect very important to endure often
elements that are visible only with the
passage of time part two is on creating
an environment for economic prosperity
seven elements of the institutions that
are important for growth and prosperity
and burton mentioned that i've been
involved in the measurement of economic
freedom which is really a project about
how what kind of institutions our
presence in in different countries and
in many ways this part two of common
sense economics is about those
institutions that really make a
difference in terms of the growth and
prosperity that a country can observe
what do we what do you highlight there
well what's more important in the
incentive structure that comes out of a
legal system that where you have
property rights clearly defined and
enforce its what's important about
private ownership is the incentive
structure giving people an incentive to
take care of things giving people in its
any to develop what they owned privately
whether they're talking about skills
that they might develop in terms of
their human capital or whether you're
talking about property of physical
property and but an incentive to develop
in a way that others value highly
because you're able to capture those
benefits and even an incentive to
conserve for the future and why that as
a student or any individual you really
don't have to worry about the world
running out of oil or running out of
this or the other kind of thing because
a market is going to solve that so relax
and enjoy it and don't worry about those
those kinds of things so but it's
incentives associated with private
ownership dynamic competition openness
of markets we've sort of highlighted
here that even in the area that we're
focused you know that innovation is
taking place and that that individual
striving to be successful they need to
be able to provide goods and services
that people value highly relative to
cost and what was successful
last week or last month or last year may
not be so successful in the future and
so you have this sort of dynamic now
that's what's really important about
competition now I know in the
introductory book that I can I
co-authored that we go into perfect
competition and present the title of the
model and all that sort of thing but we
also highlighted hey even within that
model it's this in competitive process
that's what's what's really important
well that's what we highlight is we
think about the environment for growth
and prosperity and I don't want to spend
too much time here on part two but we
obviously highlight such things as avoid
regulations that interferes with the
private agreements that individuals
would have the importance of access to
sound money the importance of keeping
taxes relatively low because high taxes
have damaging incentive effects and so
on and the importance of free trade so
essentially part two is about the kind
of why it is that some nations grow and
prosper there was a guy a couple hundred
years ago who wrote a book about that
you know something called a wealth of
nations well we cover that in part two
and really get ant what those factors
that are important in terms of creating
an environment for prosperity part 3
about is about economics in the role of
government to this group of people I
might just say part 3 is about public
choice it's about you know really in
economics often that we address the
issue about ideally what the government
might do to solve some kind of an
economic problem but that's not really
in terms of economics and learning
something from economics that's not the
important question the important
question is how would you expect this
process of voting this form of economic
organization how would you expect it to
work if you don't know anything about
how that process works you don't have
any kind of a clue about whether or not
that ideal solution is likely to be
instituted or a lot of other crazy
things under done instead of adopting
that ideal solution so we apply the
tools of economics and of course
comes out of that is this voting process
in a electorial type of process where
essentially the majority either directly
or in the typically in the form of
representative government then it has
some attributes it tends to be special
interest driven it tends to be short
sightedness and part of that short
sightedness is politicians preferred
debt financing to taxes lien does that
give us any insight about how the real
world really works do we sort of see
some governments they kind of use a lot
of debt financing you see it's important
to address this issue about how that
political process really works in the
transfer segments the limitations about
what can be achieved with taxing one
group of people and making transfers to
another group of people and empirically
looking at the evidence about how that
works okay you know it's dangerous to
give a professor of a microphone Gary
talked about being a rock star I don't
know I mean you can apply and be a rock
star but you know the problem is he
can't see how bad he looks or things of
that sort sup but so I need to keep
going part 4 is about personal finance
wow this is something that's virtually
never covered in economics classes at
either the college level and
increasingly at now it's being covered
at the high school level but students
need to know something about relevant to
making career choices how you go about
thinking about those things you need to
know things about budgeting they need to
have an idea about about savings and why
it's important to say four things you
know surprise kind of experience to have
a rainy day fund if you want because
there's a number of things that are
going to be unexpected expenses but
their unexpected only with regard to
their timing not whether you're going to
have them or not your car is going to
break down the roof is going to begin to
leak you're going to have all those
kinds of things and you can either wait
till they happen and put them on your
credit card and pay eighteen percent
interest or and lay awake at night about
how you're going to deal with your bills
or you can establish the savings fund to
deal with those kinds of things so we
highlight practical things related
to personal finance and related to
savings and investment so these are the
things that we think that students ought
to know that John Kessler is going to
come and rano may be going to speak from
from the table John but John is part of
a team that we assembled to put together
this common sense of her economics for
life involving tony feher rainy and and
john morton some of you may know mark
Shug but people who have involved our
economic education for a long time have
all contributed to this package and John
is one of our key contributors and he's
going to share a little bit more detail
we thought it'd be better to have the
non blind man do the details thank you
all well thank you for having me this
morning when 2006 I was hired by ipfw in
Fort Wayne to come up and teach their
economics courses for their non majors
and when I arrived I inherited a
textbook by Greg Mankiw from my
predecessor who had been using that i
arrived course three days before the
semester started so I had to use the the
book that was already being sold at the
bookstore found out later my students
are being charged between 150 and 200
dollars for that textbook and then were
charged an additional fee to access the
content that was on blackboard if we
wanted to use any of that and of course
we all know what the rising cost of
tuition these days one of my goals
immediately was to try to find a cheaper
version for my students who were not
going to be going on in majoring in
economics and taking any other
additional economics courses was around
that time that I was invited to a
Liberty fun conference with Jim and tani
about common sense economics and that
was how I was introduced to the book and
so I adopted it immediately he's at a
price point of about fifteen dollars for
this book it allowed me to cover the
things that I thought were essential for
these students to know and none of the
things that were really not essential
for them going
forward in life and the feedback I've
received from students is great because
they actually are reading this text book
as opposed to the other ones where they
would thumb through it and just decide
this wasn't worth their opportunity cost
so with CS e I've been very impressed
with the ability to use this to the
point where as my role as a director of
the center for economic education I've
reached out to some of the high school
teachers and our community and through
our dual enrollment process at the
University we now have between eight and
ten high school teachers using this
textbook and these materials in their
classes with their students each
semester and those students are
receiving college credit through ipfw
for taking the course so I do see the
value here I think it's incredibly
useful resource package let me just tell
you a little bit about what is inside of
here and how you might be able to use it
adapted in your course I'm each module
and the the resource is broken into
about 15 modules so that you would work
through two or three elements in the
textbook each week and cover it in about
a semesters length course and each
module you're going to start with some
pre learning questions where we ask the
students to think about their
preconceived ideas and tell us up front
what they think they know about some of
these questions that we're going to get
into they are clear learning objectives
and concepts that cover the 51 standards
from the national council for economic
education so there's a PowerPoint guide
to help them as they're reading through
the textbook to guide their thought
process and highlight the key points and
then each section has this read watch
listen and do activities in each of
these modules so they're going to read a
portion of the textbook they're going to
read some of these additional
supplemental readings that we have for
them they're going to then watch a
series of videos about the concepts
there's some listening they can be there
are actually mp3 audio files of every
single written
reading that we have for them is
available for download so they can take
that on their iPhones or on their mp3
players listen to them while they're on
the bus or driving to and from school
and for quite a few students take
advantage of that and then there's a
practical assignment that they can do
from that point so in like part 4
there's actually a budget exercise for
them one that they would pay a financial
advisor to work them through for a
couple hundred dollars we have put on
this resource package for them to use at
no cost so there's a practical
assignment attached to each one of these
then we have an assessment figure out
okay did you know how are you doing are
you catching on to this information and
then we ask them to go back to their
original pre learning discussion post
and enact with themselves prior to what
they learned and say okay what have I
learned now have I changed my mind about
what I thought I knew previously and
then we lead them with a prompt into the
next module and prepare them for what
they're going to be doing in the next
section so each of the 15 modules
follows this kind of format and has
these kinds of resources in it so I
wanted to give you to sort of a
highlight of some of the kinds of video
resources and stuff that we have
combined in here for you so take a look
at this what did you eat the brightest
orange juice with toast and strawberry
jam
that's economics that'll create jobs
watch as I worked on my lawn build a
fence and install across all saying
great I'll take yes you will and I won't
take 350 dollars for taxes whoa there's
not a single person in the world who
could make this pencil don't buy stuff
you cannot afford so that just gives you
a feel of the kinds of video clips the
students are watching as are doing this
and we have created these these sort of
interim videos to guide them with a
professor and a student having these
conversations about well why do I need
to even bother with economics what's the
point of taking this class and how does
this really relate to my life so for
each of the modules and the sections in
the book there's this conversation
happening between the student is we kind
of watch her go through the semester and
it leads them into thinking about how
these sections might relate to
themselves as they go forward so I'm
going to skip this next video because we
really don't have time to show you I was
hoping to have some time to show you
that but all boo I know deal with it
opportunity cost scarcity life sucks I
know it's all right if you want to see
it get the package it's all there ok so
the videos really are high quality and
entertaining interesting to the students
but the package as a whole is going to
give you a prenup oast test that's been
normed nationwide we've been using these
resources at a variety of schools in
high school and universities across the
country so you can compare your students
with other students around the country
each of the modules has the key concepts
and the discussion board questions
you're going to get high quality videos
podcasts classical and contemporary
readings about the concepts there are 14
assignments out of the 15 modules
there's 12 supplemental units and that
we've also created
for those of you who might be teaching a
traditional principles type course who
might want to use these resources as a
supplement for your class so there's
really a robust set of resources here
that you can use for the non major kind
of survey course or that you can use to
go into even deeper detail on some of
these concepts with your students as
well we then have a series of eight
controversial topics as well and a
comprehensive set of test bank questions
to allow for random test question
generation in the online learning
platforms so some of the supplements we
have for the traditional economics
concepts are the supply and demand
module of course it's only having one
graph and the textbook some people you
know of course have demanded more
graphing and so we have a supplement for
those who want to get into more detail
on that in a traditional course might
make sense there's a section on national
income and employment statistics so if
you want to talk about GDP unemployment
how we measure inflation those types of
questions section on monetary and fiscal
policy towards important for the
students to understand how the Federal
Reserve operates and how these things
affect the business cycle and then
lastly some of the historical economic
episodes comparing the Great Depression
with the Great Recession and how they're
similar and of course different as well
and helping students going to understand
what led to the depression what led to
the recession and what maybe we can do
about those things we also now have
created some personal finance
supplements and are hoping to put
together a resource package specifically
for those who might be interested in
doing a personal finance only type of
course so we're adding in here questions
about how to choose a career the
importance of education and skills in
the job search questions about credit
and debt and how to not get into too
much debt how to use credit wisely the
questions of investing in saving the
importance of that and then of course
insurance and spreading risk over a
lifetime those types of questions one of
the things that we are working on
currently that I'm really excited about
is our values based our faith-based
supplements we're creating a course and
resources for home school and Christian
schools currently that will be
specifically and explicitly faith based
in nature as well as one that is values
and character based for maybe a not a
non-christian school but one that still
cares about these types of issues we're
looking at questions like economics work
and happiness taking Arthur Brooks
worked on the idea of earned success and
how that leads to happiness questions of
stewardship and giving and how charity
leads to happiness and and have the
effects of that both on the giver and
the receiver of charity looking at
economics markets and morality and these
sorts of questions the economics of
poverty looking at the the idea of how
do we help people in poverty and of
course the the stuff that actin has in
that the Institute for faith work in
economics have been very helpful in
helping us organize some of these and
then lastly the economics of the
environment looking at questions of the
importers of property rights and
questions of the tragedy the comments
those sorts of things so a lot of things
going on right now with this package a
lot of great resources that are
available to you to use right away we
would love to be able to get that in
your hands and help you in any way that
we can and integrating that into your
class if you want more information
please see Fred Fred Frandsen over at
our table we'd love to get your contact
information so that we can be in touch
and see how we can adapt this to work in
your environment in your school with
your students you can email Fred and if
you really want to get kind of a sneak
peek of what's in there join us for the
MOOC that we mentioned earlier that
starts in November third you can go to
canvas net search for common sense
economics and join us I think we're a
little over you say close to a thousand
people signed up for that right now
we're hoping to have a few more before
november third but that will get you an
idea as well as the overview of what's
in this package so thank you for your
time